i've been so lucky to have my sister in
beauty at the desk co-founder of milk
makeup
boy am i going to miss her on monday but
don't worry she'll be back because we're
like this it's santa roberts rossi
hey best week ever best week ever bwe
highlight of 2020. thank you for having
me
well we've talked about doing this for a
long time so i'm just so glad we're
finally here all right xana kick us off
okay so she's beautiful inside and out
we're starting with the lovely chrissy
teigen
birdie b pots at chrissy shared her
latest skincare secret on instagram
if you haven't seen it you must watch
it's la prunier plum
oil she slathers it on and calls it holy
and amazing as soon as you watch this i
literally was on
the internet trying to find it trying to
buy it it's obviously all sold out
but it's like eight times the strength
of aragon oil and leaves skin
glowy and delicious and it's antioxidant
packed it's
true it's amazing do you see my face
right now
she's calling the development people at
flowers and we need to get plum oil i
did exactly the same with milk
not only am i excited and want to try it
but this
is the power of an influencer
social media a woman we all love know
and follow
i love her because she just says it like
it is yeah i really appreciate her humor
um but this is the power of a platform
absolutely and that's why brands want to
work with people
because this sold out boom she's so
authentic with it as well it's like
like you said she's frank and real and
fun i am
i really i just love her i'm a really
big fan
she's so refreshing all right i've got
some news
about animal crossing a video game so
widely popular
like even i've heard of it my girls play
it i mean
and it's an all-ages party for sure
nylon
magazine reports that the game's latest
update finally allows players to give
their avatars
natural textured hair and it makes a big
difference to players of color who might
want to
their mini-me to have locks or an afro
adorable hair puffs
and earlier this year animal crossing
made all skin types feel welcomed by
letting players
customize their avatars with vitiligo
acne
psoriasis i mean amazing
such a genius idea and it's about time
they reframed all these conversations
yeah that are you know notoriously
negative to something positive and
celebratory
it's like our ups story exactly i think
that was one of my favorite stories that
we got to do
completely so allowing people to be who
they are celebrating and supporting that
yeah being able to identify even if it
was a video game to find someone they
can identify with
and express yourself physically this is
who i am
live your look live your look um
hashtag news
all right dana hit us with one more
trend
this is trending in beauty edition okay
all right so for those who celebrate
christmas you can count down the 24 days
with a beauty advent calendar have you
seen the okay so there's mad hype around
these and for good reason i
mean he's even excited about that but
it's not a chocolate one you're used to
lucy this is like
full on products loxitan keels lip
smackers they all have
mega i mean every day your kids are
going to go nuts who seems like
extra excited about the advent calendar
you know what for people as well who
want to set like for brands who want to
send out almost sampling
now we're not shopping in store this is
a great way and also it's such an
amazing gift for someone because you get
a new thing every single day
so zanna is in the two girl club as am i
um her daughters are roomy and juno and
mine are olive and frankie
and both of us being moms who work in
beauty
i mean my girls are going to freak out
they are going to go i'm super they will
never do one day at a time
it's going to be taking the whole 24 and
just unpacking it look lip snacker is
doing one too
i know listen i love advent calendars
and it's so christmassy
and beauty this is perfect this is a
great thank you for bringing this to our
attention i had not known about these
oh my gosh and they're taking off on
social media as well so you can check
them out and really figure out which the
best one for you is because they all the
influence is actually opening them on
the calendars you're like oh
because i know opening is the big deal
in social media on boxing
you gotta unbox it
[Music]
you